[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno yo soy nilda soy artista plástica
desde que nací desde que tengo uso de
razón
tuve esa inclinación hacia las artes
visuales
desde que era muy niña yo juntaba
semillas palitos hojitas hacía
construcciones después con mi hermana
juntábamos arcilla de la costa yo
modelaba animales personajes y así fui
creciendo y fui formándome como artista
hice cerámica y se escultura dibujo
pintura grabado
performance vídeo performance con raquel
minetti una amiga teníamos un colectivo
de arte urbano hacíamos acciones en la
calle acciones urbanas
intervenciones
participamos en un encuentro
internacional de intervenciones urbanas
bueno y así
fui creciendo en el taller jugando
cuando terminé el secundario
mi padre tenía mucho temor por mi futuro
porque él consideraba que los artistas
mueren de hambre o sea que el 90% de los
artistas muere en la miseria y de
inanición
para colmo era la época de la dictadura
cívico-militar
y era muy peligroso ir a la escuela a la
escuela de arte y los artistas son
sospechosos son gente rara para colmo
generalmente padecen angustia cósmica y
bueno estudié bioquímica
trabajé 13 años en un laboratorio de
análisis
clínico y finalmente me fundí para mí un
alivio fue
porque era un trabajo muy rutinario y
aburrido
entonces me puse a estudiar
hice el doctorado en ciencias biológicas
[Música]
y empecé a trabajar como docente
investigador en la cátedra de química
analítica 2 también di clases en la
escuela de arte de química y laboratorio
de materiales
a mí el trabajo docente me gusta
muchísimo
el intercambio que tengo con los alumnos
ellos con esa curiosidad esas ansias de
saber que preguntan y yo me re preguntó
y tengo que buscar investigar
todo eso es muy enriquecedor para mí
bueno cuando yo terminé
la carrera de bioquímica se me planteó
el primer gran problema
tenía que encontrar una obra que me
representara o sea tenía que encontrar
un sincretismo entre arte y ciencia o
sea entre lo que hacía en el taller y la
química y esto no fue un trabajo fácil
de resolver me llevo muchos años de
labor en el taller un labor intelectual
de búsqueda
finalmente encontré empecé a reemplazar
los elementos de la naturaleza como
flores
naturalezas muertas etcétera a
reemplazarla por el lenguaje de las
matemáticas la física y la química y
entonces empecé a pintar ecuaciones y
ahí logré este esta unión entre mis dos
labores no fue fácil y fue un gran
trabajo
y lo que a mí más me asombraba era la
capacidad de creación que tienen los
científicos por ejemplo la teoría de
ptolomeo ptolomeo se pasó toda su vida
mirando las estrellas
escribió 13 tomos del alma gesto y su
teoría fue aceptada durante más de mil
años
y sin embargo aparece copérnico y dice
es falso
o sea los científicos tienen la
capacidad de crear crear realidades no
importa si son verdaderas o falsas lo
importante es que sean bellas
entonces empecé a tomar temas de la
ciencia por ejemplo tomé la matemática
de euclides y pinte una serie que se
llamaba tesoros de la matemática pintó
una serie de cromosomas sobre
manipulación genética
pinte otro que se llamaba el universo y
el tiempo que era un homenaje
a la teoría de la relatividad de
einstein
la serie de los planos de la
espectroscopía o sea me ponía a estudiar
un tema y lo volcaba en el taller
entonces allí se me planteo
una segunda problemática muy importante
también tan como la primera
que fue encontrar
un soporte teórico o un aval teórico a
lo que estaba haciendo esta mezcla de
arte ciencia
empecé a estudiar epistemología un poco
de historia de la ciencia el primer
puntapié me lo dio
y encontré infinidad de ejemplos donde
hay un nexo muy fuerte entre arte y
ciencia
desde el comienzo de la humanidad y a lo
largo de toda la historia del hombre van
juntos por ejemplo en el paleolítico en
las cuevas de altamira se encontraron
una serie de huesecillos que tienen 30
incisiones o sea que el hombre de las de
las cavernas era capaz de contar hasta
30 y repetir la operación
y además era capaz de representar con
gran maestría y con gran belleza los
animales que convivían con ellos esos
bisontes respetando colores haciendo
líneas manchas transparencias o sea que
arte y ciencia nacen juntas
y así les puedo nombrar cantidad de
ejemplos que encontré desde babilonia a
grecia en el siglo uno antes de cristo-
vitruvio que dibuja buscando la
cuadratura del círculo
ese cuadrado el círculo y en el centro
un hombre ideal de proporciones ideales
este hombre de vitruvio lo retoma
leonardo da vinci en el renacimiento
esta es una imagen muy conocida y
leonardo no era el único
artista que estudiaba ciencia casi todos
los pintores del renacimiento
estudiaron geometría para poder
representar en perspectiva el primer
libro de matemáticas en alemán lo
escribió durero que fue un gran grabador
pintor y dibujante
y así puedo seguir hablando y hablando
por ejemplo en el siglo 19 cuando cesan
rompe con esta perspectiva
renacentista y en ese momento estaba la
geometría nuclear y anna de los baches
qinghai
a principios del siglo 20 kandinsky en
su libro mirada retrospectiva dice
la sorpresa que le había causado el
conocimiento de la teoría atómica devoró
el vacío en la materia y allí comienza
su camino a la extracción lo mismo que
poner y gabo que eran dos escultores
rusos que comienzan ese camino hacia el
vacío en la materia
y bueno
infinidad de ejemplos puedo decirles de
dalí que pintaba esos relojes blandos
esos relojes que se derriten porque él
era consciente de la teoría de la
relatividad del tiempo de
deleite
actualmente los artistas van a los
laboratorios y hacen bio arte eduardo
kac que son
un artista brasilero creó el conejo alba
que es un conejo blanco que en la
oscuridad florece osea manipulan
genéticamente
plantas bacterias o animales y con eso
crean obras
bueno y así seguir
yo pensaba que iba a encontrar toda esta
mi vida de búsqueda entre la separación
entre arte y ciencia
pensaba que iba a encontrar un abismo
embargo de un límite o algo así que iba
a dar la frente contra la gran muralla y
sin embargo no encontré nada
no hay borde no hay límite no hay
murallas o sea arte ciencia nacieron
juntas los científicos son capaces de
crear los artistas son capaces de crear
y todos los hombres son capaces de crear
hay un artista alemán
del siglo 20 ya murió que decía todo
hombre es un artista
y a mí eso me llegó a reflexionar y si
todos los hombres todos nosotros no
importa el trabajo la labor que
desarrollen ustedes
son capaces de crear y lo hacen de
manera cotidiana en el momento que van a
colgar la ropa y separan las medias de
las remeras o por otro lado las sábanas
o cuando organizan la secuencia del
lavado de platos que primero lavan los
cubiertos o los vasos o las o los platos
o las ollas cuando ustedes eligen la
ropa que se van a poner ese día son
todos actos creativos en el momento que
ustedes preparan una ensalada y dicen le
falta rojo y agregan remolacha o le
agregan
zanahoria o cómo preparan un guiso
o sea es bueno
entender y que todos toda la humanidad
comprenda que todos los hombres son
capaces de crear
bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]